فاز المرشح الجمهوري دونالد ترامب في
الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوري في
ولايه نيوهامشير متقدما على نيكي هيلي
منافسته الوحيده على تزكيه الحزب الجمهوري
وتعهدت نيكيي بمواصله السباق وقالت انه لا
يمكن التصدي لفوضى بايدن بفوضى دونالد
ترامب بهذا الفوز الذي جاء في اعقاب فوزه
في ولايه ايوا يعزز ترامب فرصه في الحصول
على تزكيه الحزب الجمهوري للمره الثالثه
على التوالي لخوض انتخابات الرئاسه
وفي اول تعليق له قال الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ان الديمقراطيه والحريات الفرديه
صارت على المحك بعد فوز ترامب في
الانتخابات التمهيديه في نيو
هامشير وقد تم اعلان المرشح عن الحزب
الديمقراطي الرئيس جو بايدن فائزا في
ولايه نيوهامشير على الرغم من ان اسمه لم
يكن على قوائم الاقتراع كان الحزب
الديمقراطي قد قرر نقل المنافسه الحزبيه
الاولى الى ولايه ساوث كارولاينا بدلا من
نيوهامشير لكن حمله من التوقيعات اضافت
اسم الرئيس بايدن الى قائمه المرشحين
وتصدر بفارق كبير عن بقيه
المنافسين